Musique grandiose
-A l'Assemblée nationale,
ils sont entrés
dans la maison du peuple,
et dans l'antichambre du pouvoir.
Depuis près d'un an,
les 88 députés
du Rassemblement National
forment le 1er groupe d'opposition
dans l'hémicycle.
-Les choses ont changé,
que vous le vouliez ou non.
-Jamais nous ne baisserons les yeux,
jamais nous ne retirerons un propos,
jamais ne nous excuserons.
-Dans les murs de l'institution,
ce parti au passé tourmenté
n'a qu'une obsession :
gagner en respectabilité
et s'imposer
en alternative crédible.
-Nous venons de passer
une marche haute
vers l'accession au pouvoir.
-Ca ouvre le champ des possibles.
On se dit qu'enfin, on va avoir
des moyens pour pouvoir montrer
aux gens qu'on est compétents,
montrer qu'on va travailler.
-On sent une assurance
et une détermination
chez ces députés,
une solidarité, aussi, entre eux.
On sait qu'on va au combat.
-C'est un travail long,
pour sortir des marges
du système.
-Quelle est la stratégie
de ce RN ambitieux ?
Quels sont leurs obstacles ?
-Entendre, comprendre, décider.
-Retour sur l'année parlementaire
qui a vu ce parti s'installer
à l'Assemblée nationale.
...
-Je vous remercie.
-Bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur LCP
pour cette grande soirée électorale,
législatives 2022.
-Le 19 juin 2022 est devenu,
pour le Rassemblement National,
une date majeure,
celle de son plus grand succès
électoral.
Le parti conquiert 89 sièges
à l'Assemblée.
-Ils étaient partis modestes
dans leurs ambitions.
C'est peut-être le plus
spectaculaire, ce soir.
-Bien sûr.
-J'ai ressenti
de l'émotion.
J'ai versé ma larme, le soir,
quand j'ai vu dégringoler
l'intégralité des circonscriptions
qui tombaient
dans l'escarcelle
du Rassemblement National.
Des journées telles que celle-là,
des soirées telles que celle-là,
elles marquent une existence.
-Il y a un côté 21 avril,
finalement.
C'est un évènement politique
inattendu,
douloureux, pour ceux qui,
comme moi,
croient à la République,
se souvient de l'histoire
longue et coupable
de l'extrême droite en France.
-Un verrou a sauté
au plan parlementaire.
La capacité
du Rassemblement National
à rentrer au Parlement,
à devenir majoritaire
dans de multiples circonscriptions
en France,
dans le cadre d'un scrutin qui,
jusqu'alors,
favorisait uniquement
les grands partis.
Ca veut dire que le Front National
est devenu un grand parti.
-Bravo !
-89 députés.
88 aujourd'hui,
suite à l'invalidation d'un scrutin.
Ce chiffre se transforme
quelques jours plus tard en visage.
-Félicitations !
-Bravo, Marine. Bravo.
-Les nouveaux députés RN,
euphoriques,
entrent dans la cour d'honneur.
-Cette affaire est dingue !
-Allez-y, les dames.
-C'est bon ?
Applaudissements
-La photo de famille
est historique.
A l'Assemblée,
le RN va désormais jouer
dans la cour des grands.
Acclamations
-Je sors d'un mandat
où nous étions six.
Etre six à l'Assemblée nationale,
c'est terrible.
C'est terriblement frustrant.
C'est accessoirement
terriblement ennuyeux.
La réalité,
c'est que vous n'avez barre
sur rien.
Vous ne pouvez rien changer,
vous ne pouvez rien imposer,
vous ne pouvez rien proposer,
nous n'avions pas de groupe.
Voir, effectivement,
ces 88 députés,
c'était, là encore,
la promesse de pouvoir faire.
-Cheffe de file incontestée,
Marine Le Pen a quitté
un an plus tôt
la présidence du parti,
pour s'engager
dans la campagne présidentielle.
Elle devient, sans surprise,
présidente du groupe parlementaire
RN.
Son avenir politique immédiat
va s'inscrire à l'Assemblée.
-J'ai conscience
que le centre de gravité
de la vie politique
va se déporter et arriver
à l'Assemblée nationale,
ce qui n'était pas le cas
à partir du moment
où il y avait une majorité absolue.
C'est vrai que bon,
tout est un peu prévisible.
Il faut quand même le dire.
Quand il y a une majorité relative,
alors, effectivement,
le premier groupe d'opposition
a un rôle très important à jouer.
-Tout de suite, elle distribue
les premières consignes.
Elle insiste sur la nécessité
de se montrer à la hauteur
de l'institution,
et de bien présenter.
-La première réunion de groupe
était un discours assez long
sur la responsabilité politique
et le fait de se comporter
dignement, respectueusement,
d'honorer,
par sa tenue vestimentaire,
pour les femmes et les hommes,
le mandat qu'on nous a donné.
Ca s'inscrivait
dans un discours général
sur la responsabilité
comme premier groupe d'opposition.
-Il n'y a pas eu de mot d'ordre.
On nous demande de respecter
les lieux, les institutions,
mais aucun de mes collègues
n'aurait fait le contraire.
-Par sa taille,
le groupe RN
est en position de force
pour obtenir des postes-clés
aux bureaux de l'Assemblée,
notamment des vice-présidents.
Le règlement stipule
que la répartition
doit refléter l'équilibre
des forces politiques.
-Je sens qu'on fait partie
de l'équation.
Ils peuvent pas faire sans nous.
On est 89 députés.
Ca aurait été un tel scandale
que nous n'ayons pas
de vice-président.
J'ai plus senti
qu'on était incontournables.
Applaudissements
-Madame Hélène Laporte,
284 voix.
Applaudissements
Monsieur Sébastien Chenu,
290 voix.
-Le groupe RN
obtient deux postes
de vice-président
sur les six
que compte l'institution.
Si de nombreux députés
de la majorité
ont voté pour ces candidats,
ceux de la Nupes s'y sont refusés.
-La réalité,
c'est qu'un certain nombre
de députés de la majorité
ont glissé des bulletins
Rassemblement National dans l'urne
au moment de la désignation
des vice-présidences.
C'est ça, la réalité.
Le choix que nous avions fait, nous,
c'est de ne pas mettre le doigt
dans une forme de banalisation.
-Je trouve ça normal.
J'ai soutenu et participé
à cette démarche.
Le fait qu'il y ait
des vice-présidents
est très désagréable.
C'est même un sentiment de honte,
qu'on en soit arrivés à avoir
un Rassemblement National si fort.
C'est une réalité,
il faut y faire face.
Il faut accepter
que dans l'institution,
à la proportionnelle
de la représentation des députés,
il y ait des postes
à responsabilité
pour l'ensemble des groupes,
ceux de la Nupes et du RN.
Roulement de tambours
-Ces postes de vice-présidents
ont surtout une valeur symbolique.
Ils ne confèrent pas
de pouvoir supplémentaire,
mais permettent au RN
d'asseoir sa présence à l'Assemblée.
Hélène Laporte et Sébastien Chenu
président certaines séances
depuis le prestigieux perchoir.
-C'est très important,
parce que quand on a
un homme et une femme,
issus du Rassemblement National qui,
en tant que vice-présidents,
peuvent être à la place
de la présidente,
et organiser
les débats démocratiques,
ça montre que peu à peu,
cette homme est cette femme
on suffisamment intégré
les éléments de la culture
du pluralisme démocratique
qu'ils peuvent maintenant
les faire vivre.
-Nous faisons partie
du bureau de l'Assemblée nationale.
Nous nous réunissons chaque semaine
lors de la conférence
des présidents.
On a également
une affectation de délégation.
J'ai la délégation du patrimoine
de l'Assemblée nationale.
Je donne mon avis
sur l'entrée ou la sortie
de tel tableau, sculpture, vase,
oeuvre d'art en général.
-En plus de ces deux postes,
le RN préside plusieurs groupes
d'amitié
et d'études,
dont le plus important,
consacré à la filière viticole,
avec la députée Stéphanie Galzy.
-Exceptionnellement,
notre audition
ne durera qu'une heure,
en raison de l'emploi du temps serré
dont vous nous avez fait part.
-Bonjour à tous,
mes chers collègues.
-Jean-Philippe Tanguy préside
également une commission d'enquête
sur les ingérences étrangères,
qui a auditionné
plusieurs anciens ministres.
Peu à peu,
le RN tisse ainsi sa toile
à l'Assemblée,
au point de se fondre
presque naturellement
dans le décor.
Mais cette entreprise
de normalisation
se heurte à un mur.
-50 ans après,
vos cravates ne cacheront jamais
votre flamme !
Jamais !
-Le front républicain.
Pour la grande majorité
des autres députés,
le RN reste un parti différent.
-Pendant des mois,
pendant des semaines,
vous nous avez fait croire,
vous avez voulu nous faire oublier
qui vous étiez réellement.
Vos beaux mots, vos cravates,
ne nous ont jamais trompés.
Vous étiez, vous êtes,
vous resterez
un mouvement d'extrême droite.
-La stratégie de l'extrême droite
est d'agir comme la chauve-souris
de la fable :
dans le parti des oiseaux,
elle montre ses ailes,
dans le parti des fachos,
son poil.
-C'est pas un parti
comme les autres.
Il est l'héritier
d'une histoire longue,
de Dreyfus à nos jours.
On n'oublie pas
ce que furent les mots, par exemple,
de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
-Dans le programme
du Front National,
je ne serais pas perçue
comme française,
car je ne suis pas née ici.
Mes enfants,
dont la mère n'est pas née ici,
ne seraient pas français non plus.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
des catégories de français.
Ca, c'est profondément destructeur.
C'est un mouvement qui n'accepte pas
l'idée nationale au sens civique
des Lumières.
C'est différent, c'est dangereux.
-Le passé du RN
et son positionnement idéologique
en font un parti plus scruté
que tous les autres.
Le 3 novembre, une séance
de questions au gouvernement
va brutalement le rappeler.
-La parole est à monsieur
Carlos Martens Bilongo,
pour le groupe La France Insoumise.
-Les 134 rescapés soutenus
par l'Ocean Viking
sont bloqués sur le pont du bateau
depuis 11 jours.
Ils attendent de débarquer
dans un port sûr.
Les personnes secourues
sont en situation d'urgence.
Les météos indiquent
une détérioration...
-Pas du tout.
Ces violences...
La foule le conspue.
...
-Quel est le député
qui vient de prononcer
cette phrase ?
...
Pardon ?
-Je fais une suspension de séance
de 5 minutes.
-Tout de suite,
je suis allé voir
Grégoire de Fournas,
pour lui demander
si le sens de sa phrase
était bien de désigner le bateau.
Je lui ai fait jurer
sur ses enfants.
Le fait qu'il m'ait juré ça,
j'ai considéré
que je pouvais le défendre
de bonne foi.
-Tout de suite,
Grégoire et Jean-Philippe Tanguy
descendent dire à Yaël :
"Attendez, il y a un malentendu."
Tout de suite.
Et en fait,
le tumulte, j'allais dire,
prend de l'autre côté
de l'hémicycle qui, à mon avis,
voit une fenêtre de tir
extraordinaire,
essaye de nous faire passer
pour ce que nous ne sommes pas.
-Je crois que ça a été
la piqûre de rappel
pour celles et ceux qui,
peut-être,
avaient un peu baissé la garde.
Ils sont xénophobes,
ils sont racistes,
voilà, c'est ça, la réalité.
-On avait l'impression
d'un retour du refoulé.
Il y avait à nouveau un dérapage,
un député un peu sanguin qui,
en effet, revenait sur le terrain,
de la xénophobie,
des idées simples et simplistes.
-Malgré ses efforts
pour se notabiliser,
le RN reste un parti
très isolé à l'Assemblée.
Aucune alliance
ne semble possible
avec les autres groupes.
Pire : ses propositions de loi
et amendements
subissent un rejet
quasi systématique.
Les chiffres sont éloquents.
Au 16 mai,
sur les 1497 amendements
des députés RN
discutés en séance publique,
40 seulement ont été adoptés.
C'est le chiffre le plus faible
de tous les groupes parlementaires.
-Nos adversaires refusent
de voter les éléments
de bon sens qu'on défend.
C'est absurde.
Quand la Nupes refuse de voter
la suppression de la TVA
sur les produits
de première nécessité
alors que c'est dans le programme,
au moins, du PS,
c'est eux qui sont ridicules,
pas nous.
-Cette situation est scandaleuse,
et elle démontre,
elle est très révélatrice,
parce qu'elle démontre
que le seul groupe que le pouvoir,
dans toutes ses facettes,
craint parce qu'il représente
l'alternance,
c'est le groupe
du Rassemblement National.
-On n'a pas été élus
pour voter les propositions
du Rassemblement National.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
de très pensé,
c'est dans notre façon d'être.
-Face à cette forme
de cordon sanitaire,
les élus RN ont choisi
la stratégie inverse.
Eux revendiquent
une ligne politique d'ouverture.
-Un des enjeux de notre groupe
était de montrer
qu'on n'était pas sectaires.
Quand un amendement arrive,
on ne regarde pas d'où il vient
mais s'il améliore ou pas
le quotidien.
-On n'est pas élus
pour se faire plaisir.
Dès l'instant où un texte
est en adéquation
avec notre programme
et avec l'intérêt national,
on va le voter
quel que soit le parti.
-Voter les amendements
ou les textes des autres,
c'est aussi le chemin le plus court
pour le RN
quand il veut peser
sur les travaux parlementaires.
Le groupe a ainsi voté
les projets de loi
du gouvernement
sur le pouvoir d'achat,
la sécurité ou le nucléaire.
-La loi sur le nucléaire,
on l'a votée alors que franchement,
on trouve que ce n'est pas
à la hauteur.
On ne va pas faire
la politique du pire.
On a voté la prime
pour le pouvoir d'achat.
Ce n'est pas la mesure
qu'on voulait.
Ca peut servir quelques français
donc même si c'est pas parfait,
on le vote.
-Je ne me réjouirai jamais
que le Rassemblement National
vote l'un de nos textes
car quand on a
une majorité relative,
on doit avoir l'humilité
de reconnaître
qu'on a besoin
de partenaires politiques
pour voter des textes,
mais ce que je souhaite,
c'est qu'on ait des partenariats
avec des partis qui ne sont pas
à l'extrême droite,
ni à l'extrême gauche, d'ailleurs.
-Cette ouverture dans les votes
s'accompagne d'une attitude mesurée
en séance.
Se comporter en député modèle
pour casser l'image historique
du parti,
mais aussi pour se démarquer
d'une autre opposition.
-Il y a une concurrence
entre le Rassemblement National
et LFI.
Ils ont vu très vite
que LFI avait choisi
cette stratégie de la perturbation
de la vie parlementaire.
Et là, le Rassemblement National
a décidé de se poser
en s'opposant à cette stratégie.
Ils ont plus à gagner qu'à perdre
à cette stratégie du bon élève.
-Ce contraste
avec La France Insoumise
apparaît au grand jour
lors de l'examen du texte majeur
de l'année parlementaire :
la réforme des retraites.
Les deux groupes y sont opposés,
mais dans les débats,
les députés RN
se montrent très discrets,
en comparaison avec leurs rivaux.
Brouhaha
-Dans la réforme des retraites,
je ne les ai entendus
ni dans les hémicycles,
ni dans la rue.
Et donc, la question véritable,
c'est : à quoi servent-ils ?
-Ils n'avaient rien d'intelligent
à dire,
très peu d'amendements à proposer.
Ils n'ont fait que de ronger
leur frein
et compter un peu
sur le soutien macroniste,
ce discours contre l'obstruction
insoumise, etc.
La forme.
-On s'est pas cachés dans le débat.
On va pas se rouler au sol.
On va pas prendre le micro
et hurler,
ça n'a aucun intérêt.
On s'est exprimés
quand on devait le faire,
dans les médias.
-Là où La France Insoumise
dépose près de 13 000 amendements,
le RN en rédige un peu plus de 200,
symbole de deux approches
totalement opposées.
-J'ai toujours été persuadée
qu'il y avait une opposition
majoritaire
à la réforme des retraites
au sein de l'Assemblée nationale.
Je voulais qu'on aille au vote.
Je voulais au moins qu'on aille
jusqu'à cet article 7,
qui était le report
de l'âge de départ à la retraite.
On en a été empêchés,
en fait, par la stratégie
totalement stupide
de la Nupes.
-Sur l'ensemble
de l'année parlementaire,
le bilan du groupe RN
apparaît contrasté,
comme encore en rodage.
-C'est un bilan parlementaire
d'installation.
En fait, c'est l'ennemi qui,
tapis, discret,
tisse sa toile
au sein de l'Assemblée nationale.
-Ils ont une stratégie
de spectateur,
de spectateur engagé.
Il faut qu'ils fassent attention.
Ils ont encore
tout un travail d'opinion à faire,
sur leur capacité
à incarner une grande force
de gouvernement,
de proposition, et là,
le bât blesse.
-L'année parlementaire du RN
ne se limite pas
au travail législatif
et au débat parisien.
Elle se mesure aussi
par les sillons creusés
par ses députés
en circonscription.
Musique légère
...
Christophe Barthès
est élu de l'Aude.
...
-Bonjour.
-A Carcassonne,
une cérémonie se prépare.
-Comment allez-vous ?
...
-Enchanté.
-Ce jour-là,
c'est le 5e anniversaire
des attentats
de Trèbes et Carcassonne.
Quatre hommes,
dont le gendarme Arnaud Beltrame,
avaient trouvé la mort,
victimes d'un terroriste islamiste.
-Garde à vous !
Fanfare
...
-Une cérémonie sobre.
Christophe Barthès occupe,
dans le protocole,
la place normale
d'un député de la nation.
Roulement de tambours
-Monsieur le préfet,
comment allez-vous ?
-Très bien.
-Merci d'être là.
Merci d'être là.
Vous avez pu avoir un aperçu
de comment je suis accueilli, ici.
Je suis là depuis longtemps.
Beaucoup ne font pas la différence.
Certains sont un peu crispés
quand ils serrent la main,
mais ils serrent la main quand même.
Musique calme
-Une heure plus tard,
autre cérémonie, cette fois,
devant la mairie de Trèbes.
On retrouve les mêmes visages,
les maires, le préfet,
...
mais cette fois,
pas de député.
Christophe Barthès
n'a pas été convié par le maire.
...
-Les seuls élus présents
étaient les trois maires
concernés par ce drame.
La cérémonie officielle
était à Carcassonne.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est un moment de recueillement
voulu par les familles.
-Une explication
qui arrange bien le maire,
notoirement hostile
aux députés RN.
Musique calme
...
-Tôt le matin,
bien avant la cérémonie...
...
-Je vous remercie.
Merci, ciao.
-...prenant acte
de sa non-invitation,
Christophe Barthès
avait organisé son propre hommage,
lui aussi devant la mairie
de Trèbes.
Image à nouveau d'un RN isolé.
Pour le député, aucun doute :
si le maire de Trèbes
ne l'a pas invité,
c'est uniquement
pour son étiquette politique.
-Ca m'emmerde.
Je préfèrerais être
avec tout le monde.
Ca m'emmerde.
C'est du sectarisme à l'état pur.
C'est triste qu'on se serve
d'évènements comme ça
pour faire
de la politique politicienne,
et pour mettre les gens de côté
parce qu'ils pensent pas comme vous.
-On a tous une légitimité.
On n'a pas volé notre écharpe.
Si on est là,
c'est parce que la majorité des gens
ont pensé que vous serez
le mieux placé
pour aller les représenter.
J'en appelle à la démocratie,
à l'esprit républicain.
-Cette cérémonie
est loin d'être un cas isolé,
selon Christophe Barthès.
Dans l'Aude,
bastion socialiste
depuis des décennies,
le RN a bousculé
le paysage politique.
Il a réalisé le Grand Chelem
en reportant
les trois circonscriptions
du département.
Depuis,
les députés dénoncent
tout un système
qui serait mis en place
pour leur nuire.
-C'est quelque chose
qui est assez insidieux.
Il y a pas de prise de parole
publique pour vous attaquer.
Ca va plutôt être de l'évitement.
On va éviter de vous inviter,
on va faire en sorte que vous soyez
le moins visible possible,
pour qu'aux prochaines élections,
on dise :
"Le député RN fait pas son boulot."
-J'ai été invité, en septembre,
pour visiter une coopérative
de Limoux,
et une heure avant le rendez-vous,
quand le maire,
le président du département,
apprennent que je suis invité
en même temps qu'eux,
ils ont mis la pression
pour me décommander.
On a été obligé de me décommander
à ce moment-là.
-Dans la commune de Paraza,
le maire,
membre du Parti Socialiste,
accepte de nous recevoir.
Christophe Barthès,
après son élection,
avait proposé de le rencontrer.
Il a refusé tout net et l'assume.
-Des gens qui ont une politique
plus ou moins...
totalitaire, comme on dira,
qui ont une patronne du parti
qui a des accointances
avec monsieur Poutine,
vous comprenez bien que moi,
ça me convient pas du tout, du tout.
Je vois pas... C'est mon droit.
Je fais ce que je veux.
J'avais pas envie de le recevoir.
Tout simplement.
-Chacun est libre,
mais je pense qu'ils ont tort,
parce qu'ils vivent
dans un monde parallèle.
Ils nous accusent de choses
qui n'existent pas.
-D'abord,
ces crispations passent,
premièrement,
donc je dis à notre ami Barthès
et à beaucoup d'autres :
"Soyez confiants, et accessoirement,
soyez patients."
Et puis je vous dis que les Français
ne sont pas d'accord
avec cette méthode.
-Chacun exerce ses fonctions
de maire,
de conseiller départemental,
comme il l'entend.
Le front républicain
a diverses manifestations,
dont celle-là.
Musique légère
-En réalité,
les élus locaux et les députés
d'autres partis
ne sont pas la 1re préoccupation
du RN,
dans sa quête de normalisation.
Ceux qu'il veut convaincre
d'abord...
-Bonjour, madame.
-...ce sont les électeurs.
...
Julien Rancoule,
l'un des députés de l'Aude,
est détendu,
au moment d'arpenter
le marché de Limoux.
...
-Bonjour !
-L'accueil qu'il reçoit
confirme le message des urnes.
-Ca va, et vous ?
-Très bien.
-Impeccable.
-Restez surtout dans la légalité.
-On est sérieux. C'est ça.
-On vous attend au tournant.
-C'est ça.
On peut être d'opposition,
mais être sérieux
et respecter les institutions.
-Exactement.
Dans d'autres pays,
il y a des extrêmes droites aussi,
et ça fonctionne.
Chez nous, tout est toujours clivé.
Je pense qu'il faut un petit peu
bouger les lignes.
-Le RN,
on le trouve moins radical qu'avant.
Ils sont plus souples.
Même s'ils ont des bonnes idées,
qu'ils restent sur leur ligne
de conduite,
les mentalités ont changé.
Ils sont moins agressifs.
Plus constructifs.
-Depuis un certain nombre d'années,
on a changé d'objectif,
de stratégie,
et je pense que c'est bénéfique.
On attire autour de nous
des militants, des cadres,
qui sont vraiment présentables,
respectables,
qui ont des idées
totalement républicaines.
-Il faut tenir la distance,
pour le Rassemblement National.
C'est un travail long,
pour sortir de marges du système,
pour passer du stade
de parti protestataire,
de parti de l'excès,
au parti de la mesure,
au parti de gouvernement.
Le Rassemblement National
n'est pas au bout de ce processus.
Il faut aussi que les élus,
qui sont maintenant
autant de représentants
de ce parti
sur le territoire national,
arrivent à convaincre.
-Au-delà de l'hémicycle,
ces 88 députés donnent au RN
une assise territoriale
bien plus consistante.
Il espère l'élargir encore
lors des municipales de 2026.
Une échéance décisive pour le parti,
avant la grande bataille de 2027,
son objectif ultime.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA